transporte paralizado en parís la
mayoría de los trabajadores de la red de
metro y el tren urbano decidieron irse a
la huelga piden un aumento salarial
acorde a la inflación
vemos los precios del combustible de la
energía todo ha subido es la cuestión
anual de que todo sube excepto nuestros
salarios todo se repite cada vez hasta
el 80% de los franceses dicen sentir que
su poder adquisitivo está disminuyendo
según una encuesta de odo csa encargada
por la radio france bleu a finales de
noviembre según la compañía de
transporte público de la capital
francesa siete líneas de metro quedaron
totalmente cerradas aunque las restantes
funcionaban parcialmente los parisinos
que se desplazaban diariamente al
trabajo tuvieron que entrar a la fuerza
en la abarrotada línea 13 de metro y
viajar en un tren repleto de pasajeros
la huelga causó sentimientos encontrados
entre los usuarios que querían llegar a
sus destinos
siempre pasa lo mismo con los parisinos
siempre están en huelga cuando venimos
no piensan en los que están mal de las
rodillas pero por lo demás si lo
sabíamos
sabemos que hay huelgas y por eso para
nosotros fue una oportunidad de
redescubrir parís a pie somos de las
afueras de la capital
pensábamos dar un pequeño paseo por
parís y eso con nuestros planes pero no
importan para mí esa noche no propuse
pagar la ciudad no había visto un paro
de actividades en el metro de esta
magnitud desde que comenzó la pandemia
de kobe 19 en marzo de 2020 el tema
salarial es especialmente sensible en
las elecciones locales que también se
celebrarán en abril